[Music]
i want to talk to somebody in charge
you are not fooling anybody when you say
that what happened was a natural
disaster
you're lying it was not an earthquake it
wasn't a typhoon
because what's really happening is that
you're hiding something out there
and it is going to send us back to the
stone age
[Music]
in 1954 we awakened something
for those nuclear tests in the pacific
you have no idea what's coming
can you kill him
the arrogance of man is thinking nature
is in our control
and not the other way around
[Music]
[Music]
these are photos of an island in the
south pacific
the place where myth and science mean
we use explosives to shake the earth
helping us to map the surface of the
island
you're dropping bombs scientific
instruments
is that a monkey
magnificent you knew that thing was out
here
i'm sorry for your man colonel but if
you want to make their sacrifice
worthwhile
get us home with proof
monsters exist
your friend there can put that down
what the hell is this place that's calm
he's king around here kong's pretty good
king
keeps himself mostly well you don't go
into someone's house and start dropping
bombs unless you're picking a fight
kong's god on the island but the devils
live below us
and what are they called i call them
skull crawlers
why never said that name out loud before
it sounds stupid now that i say just
you call them whatever you want
[Music]
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here
you shouldn't come here
hello
is anyone there
i'm trying to reach
[Applause]
senators we believe that these titans
are just the tip of the iceberg
[Applause]
which of these titans are here to
protect us
[Music]
and which of these titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make godzilla our pet
no we would be his
you're sure he's gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
a rival alpha to godzilla
you gotta be kidding
[Music]
[Music]
this is our only chance
we have to take
[Music]
we need calm the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
[Music]
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
it's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here by the same
opinion
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last ones standing for
greatness
here we go no one
you